it's like one japanese dish that like i
i don't really i don't really not
recommend it but i don't really
recommend it either is when people come
here and they try the curry
because i don't know about you but no
matter where i've had curry whether it's
home cooked abroad whatever chain it all
tastes
as good as each other like i've never
had a bad curry
but i've never had a curry that just
blows me away yeah i can agree with that
every single time i have a curry i'm
like this would be great if it was an
indian curry just give me
just give me an end like an indian curry
could do this better and would taste
better right i
i mean it's just it's too one-noted
right yeah and they put scurry and
so much [ __ ] things here yeah like
there's so many like side dishes like
the one place we had ramen and the side
dish was just curry with rice
why why is it society because curry goes
with everything
that's their logic it's like how he goes
with everything everyone likes curry
you'll be happy to eat it right okay are
you talking [ __ ] about coco ichiban i do
like coco ichiban like yeah but like
because i know what i'm gonna get it's
like such a sterilized process
i'm gonna you get the same thing every
time but and it's really it really is no
different
whether you have coco ichiban abroad or
here or anything yeah
i had it in america i've had it in
exactly the exact same it's exact same
okay it's one of the only places where i
can get spice
that actually makes me feel alive bro
yeah you choose the level of spice that
is like
youtuber material so i don't know i
don't know if this this is the same
abroad but in kokochiban here you can
choose the spice level
of the curry and um 10 as as a certified
thai man who loves
thai food and spicy food it is [ __ ]
insanely spicy yeah oh yeah it's it's a
lot
except you willingly are like yes i will
have the tan and every time we've gone
to coco ichiban together
and you say yes i'll have a level 10
like
yeah they're like blinking me are you
sure
ten it's it's that's the spiciest and
you're like yeah but
one thing i don't like about the spice
level in like coco ichiban is is it
feels like fake spice
i don't know like they're this is real i
don't know it's not like when i was
having yeah i don't know i'm crying
though so i mean like
are those fake tears what what i mean by
fake spice is that it just feels like
it's added it's like a modification
it's just an artificial spice it's not
like true it's not truly a dish that was
meant to be spicy
like you have you have like a you have
like an indian curry or you have like a
thai dish and you remove the spice you
feel like
it's missing something okay i think that
in
uh an uh normal a coco ichiban spice
it's like a mainly a throat thing
yeah but in a normal curry it's like a
whole mouth meltdown yeah those chilies
get all over
yeah yeah cocoa which you man it's just
like my throat is on fire but yeah i
i love pain when i'm eating the food i
love pain like when i'm eating things
people like oh it ruins the flavor no
you don't understand
when you're like in severe pain
it makes you like the pain makes the
flavor so much more prominent it's like
a difference it's just like a different
kind of pervert isn't it
yeah i love the pain i don't understand
it's like when i
i know it's not like it's not it's not
an attractive thing to be around
something you do on a date or something
right because like i i i'm there and i'm
like [ __ ]
yeah because like okay like i remember i
remember the very first time
i felt like euphoric from from spice and
it's it's on
camera if you watch my domestic
girlfriend video
where i eat a ghost pepper um there's a
point there's a point in there well i'm
just
where i'm like explaining it i'm trying
to be a youtuber you know explaining
explaining in a funny way
and then there's a point where i'm just
like lying there for a good few seconds
and i'm just like
and like at that point like my my brain
was just rushed with endorphins and i
was
literally high at that point that i
could literally i couldn't think right
because i was just
it was painful but it was a good kind of
painful it's so
difficult to explain where it was like
downing a pint of cocaine right
that's exactly what it was like i don't
know i mean it's it's so i don't know
it's it is
i don't understand it i don't understand
it at all i mean like because people i
think
you like freak out when you when you
because jerry will try he'll be like go
on i'll try i'll try like
he'll put like an inch on his spoon
he'll try it
i just don't like when i stop freaking
out and just accept it
it's so nice okay but to be fair i used
to not be able to handle spice at all so
if we're talking
coco ichiban levels of curry because i
feel that's the easiest way to quantify
it
like i would always used to just pick
zero like lemonade
what dressing would you like water yeah
water
but yeah so i i used to be just zero
spice at all but then
the more i would try you know the more
because i will always be that one guy
and be like oh yeah i'll try this thing
that i'm probably gonna hate yeah and
spicy stuff was always one of them i'm
like yeah i know i'm probably gonna die
from this but
i'll just eat it because and spicy stuff
i think that's how i
built my spice tolerance now so now i
can do like a level two
kokuichi
all right i can still eat this and enjoy
it but i've once tried to level three i
was like
no this is to the point where the
spiciness and the pain
just completely negates all flavors for
me because
for me like moving to japan the one
thing i miss the most
spicy food spice because yeah you get a
coco ichiban ten because you can't get
any other spicy food anywhere
because like wasabi they're like hot on
the menu and it's
never hot it's it's never hot it's hot
for me
okay go on wasabi i i i have a whole
round about wasabi yeah wasabi is like
the closest thing you get to
spice but it's a totally different
feeling in the nose because
it's the spice in the nose i really like
that feeling i do but it's just not
the same as the burning sensation that's
burning tingling sometimes
yeah whereas you know normal spice is
pleasant i feel like
eating too much wasabi is like you know
you're in a [ __ ] trench in world war
ii and the chlorine gas is just landed
you know what i mean
it's like it's it's like it you do feel
like you're being gassed
it's not like spicy or like oh it
tingles it's like
ah see it's so weird because i can't do
a level three kokoichi but i love wasabi
because it's not i think people saying
wasabi spicy is wrong i feel like it
is like suffocating it's not it's not
spicy it's just it's disgusting yeah
it's
it's it's a tiny bit a tiny bit mixed in
with the soy sauce
okay we're good yeah but the moment you
put like a little bit too much on your
sushi
i love just dumping wasabi like my soy
sauce
i've i've stopped putting wasabi in the
soy sauce and now sometimes like if i'm
having like a mid
slide up the nose i'm not like i'm just
like bowl of wasabi on the sushi let's
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
it's like i take that [ __ ] directly now
i don't i don't need it
i don't need it diluted by my soy sauce
taste in the veins
directly brings this needle to the
restaurant heats up the spoon
yeah that's like downing a pint of
coconut oh my gosh
you know you know how i became to like
spice because obviously
if you haven't noticed guys i'm white
yeah yeah i can see that it might not be
a surprise to some of you i'm very white
and my my mom cannot handle any spice at
all
my mom will have like something that has
actually zero spice in it and she'll be
at the dinner table oh
it's kind of spicy isn't it mom it's
paprika it's paprika mum
it's not spicy it's paprika for [ __ ]
sake it's a spice well this water's a
little spicy
yeah yeah so naturally i was never
raised with spicy food ever
and uh what ended up happening was is
that uh started doing those [ __ ]
youtuber challenges
i would start with a ghost perfect i saw
like rhett and link do it yeah when i
was like 15.
yeah i was like i want a ghost pepper
that sounds fun so we started doing it
in school yeah we'd all do it
and you got a ghost pepper at school
yeah oh wow you could but you could buy
it at the tesco's and bring it in
we used to buy them and have a guest
talk to each other
and so i got into it and then when i
started doing live streams i kept making
donation goals i'll eat a carolina
reaper which is yeah yeah
is it still the world's hardest one i
mean it probably isn't probably made
[Music]
some abomination that's just pure gas
yeah um
but i still i must have done it like
seven or eight times and by the end of
doing it because every single 24-hour
stream i would at least do it twice
yeah and so i started like just being
like okay it's actually kind of fun now
like i would actually like look forward
to doing it
yeah and so then i noticed after doing
that where it was just pure pain
when i went back to normal curry i was
like
you can't go back there's no
yeah this is how people get into
dominatrix well
it's exactly that's exactly how this is
oh it's kind of stunning
this is literally like drugs it is drugs
it is a drug because i remember when i
first started dating sydney she could
not handle spice
at all and i remember what what got her
to start liking spice was basically
when i introduced her to my parents and
every time we'd have a family meal
mum would be like i didn't make it so
spicy for you but
in thai what making what like less spice
means just they
they take one chili out of the [ __ ]
50 they put in it's like curry right
that's what less spicy you've had the
exact same experience because when we
stayed over at god's place uh
because aki can't take spice at all yeah
and she was like oh no i'm gonna die
with this like because your mom was
making like thai noodles yeah yeah yeah
which is usually
hella spicy yeah and so i had to make a
really weird request to your mom to be
like
um can you just take all the spice out
and she like the way your mom the way
your mom looked at me was like
i was speaking another language she was
like what no
that doesn't make any sense like can you
take all the spice up oh okay
so you want one less chili no no it's
like no all
all chili's gone like it just does not
compete
it's just like this is the first time
i'm ever doing this for anybody
like i felt real it's like i felt like i
offended the time
by saying that she was just like
confused because she was like
what do you mean no spice like best
spice like more less spice
like more like what does no spice mean
that does not make sense
and so like because sydney would always
have to like eat this thai food
she would have to like at first she was
like crying every meal yeah and then as
like the more she ate the more
the more she got used to it and then now
she like she like
can handle spice better than a lot of
thai people like we have this dish
called in thailand called pacquiao
which is like which which translates to
drunken noodle
and the reason it's called drunken
noodle is that you have to be truly
pissed
to like be able to handle the spice how
much spice this is
and it's like she eats that on the daily
man see because i'm sure that if i was
put in the same position as
you or sydney yeah i would probably get
used to it too yeah but i don't want to
like i wouldn't enjoy something man it's
good get some spice in your life
it makes the meal like it gives this
extra kick to the meal that you you know
you just can't get
but that's the problem right is that
because i grew up eating japanese food
there isn't any japanese dishes that
have spice like that yeah because wasabi
is
as we've established completely
different type of spice and we don't
really use
chilies in a lot of japanese foods so
there isn't
i guarantee there's probably a lot of
japanese people who can just not handle
spice whatsoever oh yeah
i definitely i definitely feel that as
well